hi guys my name is autocrat to sneak and
I am game director of ghost runner today
I would like to show you some new
features from our game as you can see
right now we are at the final moments of
the first tutorial level which we
presented many times before we are now
standing in front of a prison tower when
the mysterious whisper who's been
guiding us through their level is
imprisoned so let's try to deal with the
guards and let's find out who release
lockdown over there prisoner released
free at last
pleasure to meet you face to face that
is now let's take a look inside this may
feel a little strange welcome to cyber
void time to fix you up you can talk
here by the way who are you you can call
me architect Who am I you're a ghost
runner number 74 to be precise that will
have to do for now your physical body is
vulnerable time runs slower here but we
should still hurry just keep moving
I will take care of your recalibration
it turns out the ghost runner isn't a
silent protagonist after all we've
decided to follow the silent warrior
archetype he's mindful of his
surroundings focused and cautious only
speaking when he really needs to the
ghost runner transitions to cyber void
which is a virtual reality network that
spans the hall of dharma tower fight
others like me before you've been cast
down from dharma city to the base
district it's a miracle to survive a
fall like that even for someone like you
and girls yes your bodyguards
peacekeepers arbitrators and anything
else we needed you to be you tried to
stop the pool there is his chance to
take a breath and ask some questions
there was a woman the name is Mara or
the keymaster as she calls herself now
20 years ago she stood against me it was
you I was trying to say you failed I
died my body did anyway
thanks to the precautions I had taken
I'm still here although this form has
its limitations are you an AI you could
say that you could also say Dharma tower
is a skyscraper technically correct
during this level the ghost runner finds
out as much as he can about his past and
undergoes a series of recalibrations
humanity's home a mega structure
it had been under my care since its
creation almost a century ago I served
the people kept him safe maintained
shelter I provided but Mara had her own
plan she became the sole ruler of Dharma
tower ruining what I've built bringing
us back to the verge of extinction
moving from cyber void represents the
process of hacking gaining access or
otherwise interacting with advanced
computer systems in this particular case
we witness that ghost runner undergoing
calibration of his protocols this will
set him up for further improvements in
the future
why can't this placement oh it's
perfectly normal
it's you that has become incompatible
the incompetent prepares you were
subjected to made you divergent who no
longer function like a ghost Runner is
supposed to but will change that uber
paired me that would be the climbers a
group of rebels
that tried to oppose Mara where are they
dead I'm afraid they'd been killed
before I managed to contact you but
there's no time to worry about them now
we're almost done here press all how did
she manage to win I was stabbed in the
back
we both were you and I who Bush was a
dear friend a trusted partner brilliant
scientist who is she now is the question
you should be asking and you wouldn't
like the answer no one among the people
of Dharma tower would
you want me to do kill Mara of course to
be able to do that you'll have to
relearn a few things and tweak your
performance but first jump we need to
get back and it's much quicker this way
will you cyber void for now we gained an
overall sense of purpose and context but
much of this world's nuance and the
story's finer points has you does
alright so we are jumping to a later
part of the game so it is not the level
that will happen right after exiting the
cyber void the ghosts honor is still on
his way for the base district towards
the upper levels of the tower right now
we would like to show you a new type of
the enemy the trigger these enemies are
equipped with out rifles and there are
way more dangerous than the enemies we
encountered before we need to be quick
and precise while dealing with them the
best moment to attack them is why they
are reloading the rifles you can also
use slopes to get to the match people
why Jack
it's the code name we used for you
during the repair Diego said you were
all jacked up when he found you and it
stuck do you mind if I call you that no
okay so who is Zoey
that was a survivor from the Congress
rebel cell and she established
communication with the ghost run and she
started providing him with an alternate
context for the places and events of
Dharma Tower
I've put together some gear
what once I plug in my a smile be able
to monitor and communication standard
neural implants
you might as you can see is a heavily
industrialised part of the tower you can
notice it while traversing all the
arena's who love as our decipher visual
and moving machinery your surroundings
can be as early as your enemies so
paying attention to where you are going
is a must
some are in us in our game are totally
Leininger but some of them are way more
open and it's up to you to decide which
way you choose you have to find out the
one that suits your playstyle the most
all right so we are done with this
section right now now we are jumping
even further than our timeline the
enemies are getting more and more fierce
and technologically advanced as the key
masters elite troops gather to protect
the elevators and you can see that they
start to look less like bandits and more
like soldiers or a militia the next
enemy that I would like to introduce to
you is called the enforcer as you can
see they are equipped with a shield so
you can't approach them frontally you
need to use your movement abilities such
as a sensory boost to get behind them
using environments such as walls
crafting points and combining it with
your movement abilities is the way to
outsmart them so here is another example
of protection for the enemies in our
game this guy is protected by that blue
energy so let's find out if we can break
it this type of protection is called the
beacon shield
so to kill the protected enemy first we
have to destroy a vision just like that
number of beacons and number of the
protected enemies may vary it's up to
the player to spot them and to prepare
the right plan for execution okay so we
are back to cyber void in order to learn
a new skill
the ghost runner was able to download
data on one of the techniques used by
his kind called The Tempest energy in
your right hand and then cut it all out
what don't try to think do it now time
to test it out in the safety of the
cyber world before using it in actual
combat so basically it works like a very
strong wave of the energy accumulated in
your hand which can push away and kill
the enemies it's just a visualization
anyway how does it work in the real
world
rapid micro vibrations your inner
hydraulics
sudden change in local pressure will
result in a concentrated blast let's
hope that piece of jump the climbers
used to replace your are in handle it
but Japanese theme corresponds to the
fact that the whole Tower and the cyber
quality along with the ghosts rhymes
were created by a single man the
architect the primary application was
crowd control not three foot boards of
course there's no need to restrain
ourselves now he was fascinated by
Japanese culture well during his elite
body guards after historical warriors as
well as including visual references to
Japanese aesthetics throughout many of
his designs
one more thing you can use tempest to
deflect projectiles give it a try yes
you can also use tempest to reflect
enemy projectiles but you have to time
it right because the effective range is
limited just a bit more practice
actually it is possible to deflect the
bullets with your soul and it is one of
the upgrades which you can get while
your character is progressing but our
character progression system is
imperfect for another video ok we are
back on the same level where we
introduced to you
the enforcer enemy and it is time to
meet the next one called slugger
they are the melee type of enemy who can
be very deadly if we are not fast enough
so stagger can jump on you using the
Palio effective act or if you come too
close to him you can just attack use his
huge fists so the way to deal with them
is to dodge the attack by dashing back
or sideways you can also use your
central evil it does them as you can see
in the bottom left corner our special
ability is almost ready to use you can
refill the energy bar by killing the
enemies but a small amount of energy is
also refilling over time ok so now we
have a more complex arena in front of us
we've got 2 enforcers beacon shield and
one and even with a pistol so let's fill
our tempest ability and try to use it so
we can forget about the beacon because
tempest is so powerful that it can
destroy all types of protection it's
also kind of tactical approach to our
fast-paced gameplay where you have to
figure out when
and on which type of enemy using your
special ability will be the most
effective
okay so let's jump even further on our
timeline here we are in around 1/2 of
the game we want to show you a totally
new setting and a few new mechanics the
ghost runner reaches Dharma City a metro
police situated above the base level
that has been traversing them till now
you've never been here no I told you the
keymaster only allows those loyal to her
and only Mara strictly controls the flow
of
the residential and commercial powers of
Dharma turns out to be even more proudly
the keymaster soldiers than the base but
there is no turning back
here is the next type of enemy drone as
you can see it's rotated back to us so
we can try to use our gap jammer to jump
right on to it so as you can see we can
steer it a little bit so it's also very
convenient way to travel from one dermis
[Music]
so where do we go what's the next step
okay here you go
just how to download the layout here
we've got two drums we are lucky that
their spotlights are facing down so
let's try to use them as our
transportation method and this is
another cool thing about drums we can
use their explosion to kill other
enemies on the ground okay so in front
of us we'll get cyber void uplink
openings are places where the ghost
runner can access and disable his safer
to limiter affectively overclocking his
own body and allowing himself to achieve
extraordinary feats for a short period
of time
this particular opening allows him to
jump super high which is very convenient
in dermis its rooftop setting there will
be a key other type of cyber void
uplinks which you will be able to use in
ghost runner let's take a look at this
arena we have several ways to go but as
you can see these enemies are protected
for it to be concealed
so let's find their source of this
protection
and here we can use a rail or a super
jumbo plane to get
okay so we have to remember that there
is also the trigger enemy without the
rifle so let's try again and tempus is
now ready to use
so let's use it alright so these two
remaining enemies are no longer
protected with a beacon shield so let's
approach them from behind and that's it
for this presentation thank you for
watching and go sooner we'll come to PC
and consoles later this year so please
stay tuned
this is troublesome